vous êtes dans trois réalités
différentes une réalité qui est plus
lointaine gaspésie daley le côté je
commence avec vous est ce que c'est un
grand soulagement de vous voir passer en
zone jaune c'est à dire rassemblement
permis d'engager de bulle familiale les
restera basse étaient déjà ouverts mais
on a laissé plus de couvre-feu du tout
chez vous c'est un soulagement j'imagine
effectivement parce que plus ça allait
et plus les gens avaient des difficultés
à suivre à suivre les règles en vigueur
a imposé un couvre feu imposé plusieurs
restrictions alors qu'elle est
pratiquement plus aucun corps actif dans
le milieu ça devenait difficile pour les
gens de suivre celle de comprendre tout
ça donc les gens réclamaient d'avoir un
peu plus de liberté si on veut en fait
depuis le retour de la période des fêtes
on avait pratiquement aucun caractère
j'ai eu des micros éclosion à gauche et
à droite mais toujours très très très
circonscrites donc le passage en zone
jaune si on veut avec plus de plus de
liberté plus de lettres sur le retour de
nos enfants sur les bancs d'école plus
activités parascolaires un peu plus de
pratique de sports bert c'est un soupir
de soulagement pour les gens le petit
souper entre deux familles la drogue aux
maisons privées sont super didier à la
santé physique et la santé morale ou
parce que j'imagine que vous viviez une
espèce de décalage entre ce que vous
entendiez comme consignes venant soit de
la métropole soit québec laval et c est
ce que vous viviez il avait dit boillon
n'y a pas aucune commune mesure
en fait c'est sur les gens commencent à
avoir des difficultés à comprendre et à
vouloir dîner appliquer ces mesures les
gens qu'on comprenait quand même que de
façon globale au québec y avait quand
même encore plusieurs correctifs que la
capacité du système de santé des limites
et ecce terra les cas s'il voyait qu'ici
les autres tous les deux des quatre
hôpitaux de la gaspésie avait aucun
aucune hospitalisation qu'on avait
parfois 0 caen actifs long à monter au
long de présentement une vingtaine vous
disiez mais la vingtaine en fait c'est
un des gros chiffres revus depuis le
retour des failles alors ne tourne
toujours aussi à quelque part entre 0 5
et 10 corps actif pour un territoire qui
est grand à peu près comme la belgique
tellement ces gars la gaspésie donc les
gens avaient un peu de difficulté à
suivre tout sort maintenant
le pont des soupirs de soulagement parce
que des gens qui auraient aimé avoir une
plus grande liberté encore cédé correct
que le gouvernement y avait de façon
progressive comme il le fait
actuellement ont commencé tranquillement
se réadapter à réadapter dans nos moeurs
nos habitudes parce que cette nouvelle
latitude l'homme est ce que je souhaite
c'est que je boucle et comme on dit par
chez nous quand on donne un faux super
très inquiets j'espère que l'on se doit
d'imposer avons accepté de prendre
seulement se pousse trop pour l'instant
et qu'on veut continuer d'y aller
progressivement pourquoi que ça ne faut
pas que ça décolle michel angers
shawinigan vous êtes en zone orange donc
le changement qui sera apportée il n'y a
pas de changement pour le couvre-feu
c'est toujours j'étais 1h30 chez vous
mais un changement important pour les
jeunes qui vont pouvoir secondaire
retourner à temps plein à l'école tu
importance changé mais tout à fait je
pense que les jeunes appréhendés que ce
signal de pouvoir enfin reprendre les
activités normales scolaire mais j'ai
effectivement comme vous l'avez
mentionné n'y a pas grand chose qui a
changé pour nous toutefois quand nous
sommes passés de la zone rouge à la zone
orange a déjà dansé et un soupir de
soulagement pour plusieurs
particulièrement pour les restaurateurs
les salles d'entraînement les cinémas
alors ça a été vu comme un élément
positif qui fait que du côté de la
mauricie de shawinigan on avance je vous
cache pas que depuis plusieurs semaines
on flirte avec la zone des gens
regardent les gens regardent un peu la
presse les différentes courbes qui est
là lorsque plusieurs parce qu'il faut se
rappeler que mauricie centre du québec
ce sont deux régions administratives qui
sont distincts mais regroupés sous le
même ciel est donc là sans du québec a
été beaucoup plus impactée par la
deuxième vingt que la mauricie qui
l'avait été lors de la première vague
il voudrait que du côté shawinigan n'y a
pas beaucoup de cas depuis de nombreuses
semaines quelques cas pas de variants
pourriez alors je pour sûr que les gens
s'attendaient à ce qu'on bascule du côté
gens parce qu'on vient à peine de
rentrer dans la zone orange mais chose
certaine bon vous savez on est un peu
enclavé par faire beaucoup beaucoup de
régions qui sont un peu plus un peu plus
impactés mais ceci étant dit
nous avons continué à faire la promotion
des différentes mesures sanitaires pour
qu'on puisse rester dans cette situation
et que minimalement les la vaccination
vont nous permettre enfin de traverser
la prendre racontez moi quand même un
peu le changement les changements qui
sont apparues comme j'avais basculer en
honorant la restauration tout ce que
vous avez vu un argument on a vu des
reportages la première journée mais ce
que est ce que ça continue comme ça les
gens ont envie d'aller socialiser un peu
en tout cas de toute façon on avait
travaillé extrêmement fort sur l'achat
local encourager nos commerçants et a
évidemment pour avoir une place en
restaurant à shawinigan le samedi
dimanche dernier il fallait s'y prendre
très très tôt à orly en fonction du
nombre de personnes qui étaient permis
pour chacun des restaurants c'était
bondé partout je pense que les gens
attendent et ce avec énormément
d'impatience et j'ose espérer que bien
évidemment le couvre-feu faire en sorte
que les gens devaient quitter tôt donc à
29 eur 9h15 c'est quand même un peu un
peu serré mais ceci étant dit les gens
voyaient enfin la lumière au bout du
tunnel
et cela pour le moral un peu comme le
maire de gaspé on nous disait pour le
moral des gens c'est extrêmement
important
c'est vrai pour les jeunes à l'école
mais c'est vrai aussi pour les adultes
qui attendent depuis longtemps
enfin c'était cette bouffée d'air frais
alors monsieur gariépy à saint sauveur
j'imagine nous est un peu déchiré parce
que vous êtes bon toujours zone rouge
parce que les laurentides sont près de
montréal
alors on ne veut plus dissocier comme on
avait fait il y avait deux couleurs
autrefois mais j'ai autrefois ça me
paraît tellement long mais il ya
quelques mois
est ce que vous êtes conforté avec le
fait que vous êtes toujours rouge à
saint sauveur bah écoutez on a quand
même eu des bonnes nouvelles
c'est sûr que mes deux collègues ont
plus de 2 sur 10 mais qu'on peut le
savoir
à saint sauveur mais on prend notre
plaisir ou ont ponctué ce que ça me
donne à saint sauvage que ça me donne un
seul joueur s et des sports c'est de
l'espoir
je le sais que dans quelques semaines
l'envoyeur
on va être en retard en jeu les
restaurants sont ouverts mais doit pour
l'instant quand
une le couvre-feu voici très riche en or
et 21h30
c'est quand même sur deux qui je pense
aux travailleurs qui reviennent à la
maison ça lui donne quelques heures de
plus pour aller au marché d'alimentation
ou peu importe d'en faire un petit peu
un petit peu de commission le soin
qu'ils vont trouver à faire qu'on ne t'a
pas avait donc non c'est pas beaucoup on
est encore dans une loge en a cinq
qu'aux actifs à saint sauveur une neuve
dans la mrc des pays d'en haut
donc on est quand même assez bien
disciplinés sinon je suis venu les
consignes mais aussi que dans les
laurentides yacht club ça qu on est à 35
minutes de laval l'a 45 minutes de
montréal dont on le suppose tout convois
convoi tombe orange envoyait deux
ouvriers travaillent ici puissent pop et
jora type de dire son nom je comprends
belvédère vos commerçants font leurs
affaires avec les gens qui viennent de
la grande région de montréal notamment
je vous pose la même question ou 3 est
ce que vos citoyens arrête pas de vous
envoyer soit des courriels où vous vous
parle quand vous vous promenez dans la
rue pour que vous fassiez des pressions
auprès des députés auprès des ministres
pour
donner un peu d'oxygène je commence avec
vous donnez le côté tour de table by pas
vraiment d'un tenant lui un peu de
pression surtout au printemps en fait
les gens étaient devant l'inconnu avec
les assouplissements qu'il y ait eu à
l'eau des paillettes par exemple
honnêtement et on était très peu
interpellé par contre on va le chercher
quand même le pouls de la population
on discute fréquemment avec la direction
régionale de santé publique et moi
j'étais très honnêtement j'ai voulu très
politisé les questions de santé publique
en france à prendre certaines expertises
pour travailler là dedans donc on sera
beaucoup de notre directeur régional qui
lui fait beaucoup des représentations
nationales
quelquefois sont des discussions avec
par exemple autre ministre régional on
peut glisser quelques mots sur ce qu'on
vous perçoit ce qu'on ressent de la
population mais dire qu'on a subi depuis
plusieurs mois et dorian de pression
citoyenne et qu'on a transféré cette
pression-là sur les épaules du
gouvernement ce serait vous mentir on
trouvait beaucoup plus avec la santé
publique
plutôt que d'y aller avec des prêts sont
parce que les députés nous raconte qu'un
il recevait les appels de pleine mer en
valeur nous on veut on veut des confiné
on peut changer de couleur à vous dit
vous n'avez pas vient pas parler aux
politiques du tout à nouveau député à
votre ministre responsable capital
politique avec sourire avec vous on ne
reçoit un peu de pression bien de
toujours un peu de pression aux citoyens
c'est correct
les pressions vont dans tous les sens
certains ont pas énormément du virus
soit des mesures très récent et autres
veulent regagner de la liberté l'écart
entre les deux à quelque part mais on
est plus en mode discussions avec la
santé publique
mais je vous mentirais ce soir en vous
disant que j'ai téléphoné tous les jours
à ma députée ou à vos ministres
régionaux
oliver dépression challenge et comment à
shawinigan de cette relation là avec le
gouvernement québécois soit la
députation des mines scc joué on a parlé
très peu la réputation ni au ministre
régional belge vous cache pas qu'au
niveau des citoyens vous vous rappelez
qu'il recherchait s'élever la flèche
lors de la première vague 44 morts savez
ça va frapper beaucoup plus que
l'imaginaire auprès de notre population
donc pour beaucoup de citoyens qui font
des pressions pour qu'on puisse
avoir de meilleur rang de meilleures
conditions des largesses comme tels ou
des assouplissements
par contre au niveau des restaurateurs
des propriétaires de salles de deux
d'entraînements au niveau des
commerçants aussi même si j'ai eu de
l'aide qui ont été là gouvernementale
qui a été octroyée qu'on a su porter on
a aidé je cache pas que commençait à
sentir que la fatigue est en train de
prendre et je pense que oui on a parlé
évidemment avec la santé publique dans
l'espoir éventuellement de de passer du
rouge ou alors en jeu lors de la
première fois ce cap a été le cas lors
de la deuxième fois on a eu des
discussions on a d'ailleurs des réunions
régulières avec la santé publique et on
nous dit on nous donne des indicateurs
que nous n'avons pas et un peu comme
comme mon collègue côté le mentionner on
a l'intention de respecter les consignes
la santé publique moi j'en fait la
promotion depuis le jour 1 nous assurer
qu'on soit capable de respecter
l'expertisé de ceux qui le lie au final
se garer et p les gens dans la région
tient souvent sont déchirés oui les
commerçants vivent avec la visite comme
on dit mais en même temps on n'avait pas
trop alors un coma j'imagine que vous
receviez des pressions des deux côtés
vos citoyens vous nos commerces 1 puis
hier et ce ratage surtout comprenez
exactement la situation dans les
différentes sorties que j'ai fait la
ligne était tout le temps clair c'est
faire en sorte que la santé des citoyens
soient protégés puis de d'éviter les
éclosions potentiels alliés de faire
ensemble de saint sauveur on le sait que
lorsqu'il fait beau les fins de semaine
arrive dire beaucoup beaucoup de monde à
saint sauveur ont faim sorte on à bouche
d argent du culte et pourtant ça que les
gens soient protégés les gens au
contraire nous demandaient les les
courriels et les la correspondance je
recevais c'était continuer à nous
protéger on veut et protéger en vue pour
décrocher un point clé restera par
comprenez exactement mais je vous
qu'actuellement ils y ont peut-être
parle de reprendre un chiffre qui sont
tannés oui faut penser que ces charlots
il ya un travail à faire
ils font bien
puis sordo pour perdre de l'argent ils
sont là pour affaires puis son lot pour
un cordon citoyen ils peuvent pas le
faire actuel daniel côté maire de gaspé
michel angers maire de shawinigan jeune
carrière pigeât gariépy maire de
saint-sauveur merci nous allons parler
ce soir 3 réalisé trois couleurs 3 2
c'est comme ça merci beaucoup merci à la
fois c'est sûr